you are human made from carbon that was
born in the heart of a dying star
that traveled light years through space
that was previously part of countless
other materials
other life forms maybe even alien life
forms
those carbon atoms form the roughly 37.2
trillion cells that comprise the human
body
although that's only the current
estimate every single one of those cells
will replace itself within seven to ten
years from now
you are not the matter that makes up
your cells then but the information that
they carry
the programming that transforms that
star dust into living matter
most of those cells contain a perfect
blueprint of your body
an identical genetic code stored within
the nuclei
the most efficient form of data storage
we know
a single gram of dna could potentially
store 250 petabytes of information
that's 215 million gigabytes but these
cells don't all act the same
each cell knows how to behave according
to its location in the human body
thanks to gene expression different
genes are active at different locations
in the body
allowing the bone cells to act like bone
cells and brain cells to act like brain
cells
allowing us to negotiate with our
genetic destiny
[Music]
any two people share roughly 99.9 of the
same genetic code
but that small 0.1 percent is enough to
account for more than 3 million
differences
so different are we that there are
muscles that only exist in a portion of
the population
twenty percent of the population lack
the triangular abdominal muscles
called the pyramidalis for example
each of us carry mutations that make us
entirely unique
unprecedented we're all x-men and in
rare cases
these differences can have far-reaching
consequences
consider the rare individuals born with
mutations on both
mstn genes that can build up to 100 more
muscle mass than average humans
what is your unique variation and yet so
related are we that if you go back to
between 5
300 and 2200 bc you reach the genetic
iso point a time in history where every
single individual on the planet today
shares the exact same ancestors
we are at least 50th cousins
[Music]
you may even be carrying relatives in
your own body some people called
chimera carry more than one set of dna
this can happen when a twin is absorbed
by its siblings embryo in the womb
go back much further and we find that we
are related to every single animal on
the planet too
we all come from luca the last universal
common ancestor
that emerged four billion years ago
or do we there are those out there that
believe that there may be an entirely
different species
living on this planet that does not
share our genetic heritage
a shadow biosphere that could be hiding
in earth's most inhospitable places
perhaps even its magma if this were ever
discovered to be true
that life form would be just as
different from us as an extraterrestrial
life form
you are a human with a brain comprised
of over 100 billion brain cells called
neurons
and 125 trillion synapses in the
cerebral cortex alone
that's more than 1 500 times the number
of stars
in the milky way galaxy it's no wonder
that the human brain is hailed as
the most complex known object in the
universe
and it sits inside your skull be careful
with it
we know now that the human brain has a
nearly unlimited ability to change and
adapt in response to environmental cues
so plastic is the human brain in fact
the way to lose an entire half of your
brain in what's known as a
hemispherectomy
the remaining half would adapt to take
on the jobs of the missing portion
hemispherectomy patients very often
retain the vast majority of their
cognitive functions
with just half their brain were you to
lose your sight
you could train your hearing to the
extent that you may develop echolocation
that means that you can navigate with
sonar by using clicking noises like a
bat
the human brain is so powerful that
gifted individuals throughout history
have developed equations so accurate as
to predict the shape of the universe
itself
at any point in time we have no idea how
the brain generates our experience of
consciousness
or even truly how to define
consciousness at all
you are a human a collaboration not a
single organism but a super organism
made from other species those species
are the bacteria that live inside our
bodies and perform crucial symbiotic
roles
they produce neurochemicals and hormones
to alter mood they break down food
they battle among themselves in order to
we hope fend off harmful invaders and
keep us in constant balance
even the mitochondria that reside inside
our cells
that are considered as much a part of us
as our very bones
are in fact the evolved form of an
entirely separate alpha proteobacteria
that lived over 3.5 billion years ago
and so it is that our mitochondria have
their own entirely different set of dna
you are human capable of complex dynamic
and powerful movement
a member of a species that is able to
mimic nearly every other species on the
planet
that movement is infinitely more complex
than we inherently recognize
when you send a signal to your bicep it
will innervate 774 motor units
delivering the precise amount of force
required to execute the movement
except that we are only ever able to
engage a fraction of these muscle fibers
at a time
estimates suggest that even trained
athletes only ever utilize 50
of their motor units and those are
mostly the smaller
less powerful kind this restraint
mechanism
exists for self-preservation we are too
powerful for our own good
were we able to contract every fiber at
once we'll be able to leap
high into the air stories of crisis
strength suggest that we gain this
ability in response to dire need
giving rise to urban myths of mothers
raising cars off the ground
to save their children or viking
berserker warriors
that could turn the tides of war
single-handedly
as it is a trained boxer is capable of
delivering around 5 000 newtons of force
this relies on a specific network of
muscle activation
called the serape effect and is equal to
half the force
that a one-ton car exerts on the ground
a baseball pitcher can throw a ball at
over 100 miles an hour
but muscles are not just machines used
for force generation
muscles are secretory organs that
release complex chemicals
to alter countless other processes
throughout the body and they are sensory
organs
that provide us with feedback about the
world around us through muscle spindles
and golgi tendon organs every part of
your body is infinitely more complex
than it appears at first pass
we combine this with information from
our other senses our sight and sense of
balance
equilibrioception in order to generate a
mental model of our entire body
and where it is in space at any given
time this tells us precisely how much
force we need to generate on each
joint simultaneously to stabilize or
mobilize
and achieve the desired outcome
this is done with the help of fascia a
complex catsuit of connective tissue
that spans the entire body
and even enters and fills the muscles
themselves the fascia
observed by leonardo da vinci was
originally discarded as an inert film
wrap
until recent studies revealed it to be
much more a substance that contains its
own muscle cells and nerves
and that can even help to convey force
from one muscle to another
across vast distances throughout the
body all this information
forms our perceptual motor landscape
this is not formed of individual senses
but rather coalescence of data from
multiple inputs
that together create an impressionistic
picture of the world around us
this is multi-sensory integration
this is not the truth but the lie we
need to believe in order to enhance our
chances of survival
and in fact it is delayed by the time it
takes for the last signal
to reach our brain such that an
artificial snapshot can be created by
combining that information
into a single unit of now a
psychological present
neuroscientists now use mathematical
models to better understand the brain
many describe the brain as a bayesian
prediction machine
a system designed to anticipate changes
in the world around us
to predict the most likely outcomes and
to thus allow us to move in the most
useful ways
a batter cannot react to a baseball
being thrown at them they can only
anticipate that movement based on
telegraphing
and other minute cues and countless
prior experiences
of trial and error
consider that the smartest ais created
by humans are capable of beating chess
masters
but our best robots can't even come
close to matching a toddler
in a task as simple as picking up an
orange
neuroscientist daniel walpert believes
that the brain exists
for movement and proponents of embodied
cognition
believe that without a physical
experience of the world around us
we would be unable to internalize
concepts and ideas
unable to think
you are human an adaptoid mutable
constantly changing human bones that
appear so rigid
are in fact banks for minerals that are
constantly broken down and reabsorbed
so plastic is the brain that our life
experience even changes the way we
perceive the world around us
and handle the very process of thought
wrestlers are more inclined to use their
brain's motor regions
when performing tasks such as mentally
rotating 3d objects
as compared with the general population
we can grow new capillaries blood
vessels
to supply the most often used muscles
with more blood this can increase that
muscle plasticity
and our fascia can remodel itself in
response to common patterns of movement
we can even change the expression of our
dna altering which genetic code is
active and which is dormant
resulting in profound changes that we
can even pass on to our offspring
thanks to this changeability we are
shaped by our environments
our limitless potential is forged into
something powerful and concrete
as we learn to move optimally through
space and time
this change is arranged around the
interplay of organism intent
and environment we crave this learning
process
we are information processing machines
we have dopamine pathways built into us
that makes us yearn for challenge
stimulation and growth
this is what play is the difference
humans are the only species on the
planet that can change their
environments to this extent
when we choose to train we change the
environment to elicit the changes we
want
to tap into more of that unlimited
possibility
many humans have accomplished incredible
things this way
things that were once seemingly
impossible
you are human you are limitless remember
that when things seem tough
your entire body is built to adapt and
thrive in the hardest of times
you're capable of incredible things
you're made from primordial matter
born in the heart of a dying star you
got this
and so it is that i also believe
training should encompass
much more than just curling and
squatting your body is capable of so
much more
built for so much more and you can grow
in every single one of these areas
why not take that same growth mindset
and apply it to every aspect of your
performance
if you like this philosophy then be sure
to stick around and check out some of my
other videos
i have discussions on everything from
how to increase your working memory
to how to hold your breath longer to how
to perform cool calisthenics moves
if you want a ready-made training
program that can help you develop much
more than just your bench numbers
then check out my ebook and training
guide super functional training
that's a pdf and much more that you can
find in the description
down below there's a discount on right
now while we're all struggling with a
pandemic
i also have a book available for
pre-order called functional training and
beyond
that's a detailed look at the concept of
training for real life and sports
and you'll find that in the description
too thanks so much for watching this one
guys
i was trying something a bit different
here let me know what you think i
discovered so much awesome stuff about
the human body while researching these
posts
but i thought it could be cool to put
all of that together into something a
little motivating
i thought that might be fitting for the
new year
if you did enjoy it then please leave a
comment like it share it around
hit the subscribe and notification
buttons all that helps me out immensely
and i massively appreciate your support
i hope you all had a great break over
the holidays and that 2021 is amazing
i think we all deserve it to be a really
good one
and guys stay tuned because i've got
another exciting and different video on
the way
next it might take a little bit longer
than usual but i'm working on the
new batman training program for 2021
it's called the i am vengeance workout
thanks to time for watching this one
guys
and bye for now
you